EVERY WEEKDAY AT MIDNIGHT
EASTERN HOSTING
"FOX NEWS @ NIGHT."
THANK YOU, TRACE.
THE NEW TOUR CALLED LET WOMEN
SPEAK IS INTENDED TO GIVE WOMEN
AN OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK ABOUT
GENDER IDEOLOGY.
YESTERDAY THE EVENT ARRIVED IN
NEW YORK CITY NEAR CITY HALL IN
MANHATTAN.
QUICKLY TRANS ACTIVISTS
DESCENDED ON THE EVENT AND BEGAN
THREATENING THE ATTENDEES.
>> [BLEEP]
[BLEEP]
I WILL.
DO NOT DISCRIMINATE.
I WILL [BLEEP]
YOU UP.
MORE REAL THAN YOU WILL EVER BE.
NO MAN WANTS TO.
NO MAN WANTS YOU.
>> Will: I LOVE TO ASK THE
PRODUCERS OF THE SHOW WHY ONE
INDIVIDUAL'S CHEST WAS BLURRED
AND THE OTHERS WAS NOT THAT I
CAN'T FIGURE OUT THE DISTINCTION
FACTOR.
THE POLICE IN THIS INCIDENT SAY
NINE PEOPLE WERE ARRESTED AT THE
EVENT.
A PRO-FEMALE ACTIVIST AMONG THE
ATTENDEES WHO WAS THREATENED IN
THE VIDEO THAT YOU SAW.
SHE WAS ON THE OTHER SIDE OF THE
THREATS AND SHE JOINS US.
THANK YOU FOR BEING WITH US.
WHAT TO DO IT FOR LIKE IN THE
MOMENT?
WHAT WAS THE ENERGY AROUND THAT
EVENT?
>> >> DANGER.
THAT WAS THE ENERGY AROUND THE
EVENT.
IT WAS VERY HIGH ENERGY.
IT WAS NOT GOOD.
I DON'T THINK I EXPECTED IT TO
BE THAT BAD.
OBVIOUSLY WE WERE.
WOMEN WERE ASSAULTED.
POLICE WERE ASSAULTED.
I CAN'T BELIEVE HOW MUCH ABUSE
THEY PUT UP WITH.
IT'S UPSETTING TO SEE THE SPIN
OF THE NEWSPAPER THAT IT WAS
EITHER AN EQUAL FIGHT OR THAT
THE POLICE WERE BEING BRUTAL
AGAINST PEOPLE BECAUSE THAT WAS
NOT THE CASE AT ALL.
>> Will: TELL ME WHAT YOUR
ORGANIZATION IS, I ASSUME ON THE
OTHER SIDE OF THIS INCIDENT,
PEACEFULLY PROTESTING.
WHAT WERE YOU HOPING TO
HIGHLIGHT?
>> I CAME OUT TO JOIN THE LET
WOMEN SPEAK TOUR THE LAST COUPLE
WEEKS BECAUSE I WANTED TO
EXERCISE MY RIGHT TO FREE SPEECH
WITH OTHER WOMEN.
WE CAME OUT TO BE PEACEFUL AND
TALK ABOUT THE HARMS OF TRANS
IDEOLOGY.
WE ARE ALL ACROSS THE BOARD
POLITICALLY.
ALL AGES, ALL ABILITIES,
EDUCATION, EVERYTHING, AND WE
ARE JOINING TOGETHER BECAUSE WE
KNOW WHAT IS HAPPENING AND WE
WANT PEOPLE TO KNOW, WE WANT TO
GO TO THE STREETS AND TALK TO
ANYBODY WHO IS PASSING BY AND
WHO WILL LISTEN.
>> Will: IT'S ALMOST AS THOUGH
THE INDIVIDUALS IN THE VIDEO
WERE INTENT ON PROVING YOUR
POINT.
YOUR EVENT IS LET WOMEN SPEAK
AND NOW YOU HAVE THESE MEN
DRESSED UP AS WOMEN ATTEMPTING
TO SHOUT YOU DOWN.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
THIS IS A RECORD OF OUR DISSENT
AND THEY ARE DOING THE WORK FOR
US.
THEY ALWAYS COME OUT.
THEY SHOW THEMSELVES TO BE
EVERYTHING THAT WE SAY IS THE
REASON WHY WE DO NOT WANT THESE
PEOPLE, THESE MEN, THESE VIOLENT
MEN FOR THE MOST PART COME IN
OUR SPACE IS INTENDED FOR WOMEN
AND GIRLS.
>> Will: AS YOU TRAVEL THE
COUNTRY, I AM CURIOUS WHAT HAS
BEEN YEARS SINCE OF SAFETY?
WAS THIS A PARTICULAR BAD
INCIDENT?
HAVE YOU BEEN MET WITH THIS TYPE
OF REACTION ALL ACROSS AMERICA.
>> ALL ACROSS AMERICA.
SAN FRANCISCO, PORTLAND, SEATTLE
WAS CANCELED DUE TO THREATS OF
VIOLENCE, CREDIBLE THREATS OF
VIOLENCE.
WE WERE ATTACKED IN TACOMA AND
OBVIOUSLY YESTERDAY IN
NEW YORK CITY, THERE WERE
SECURITY GUARDS HIRED FOR
AUSTIN, CHICAGO, D.C. LAW
ARRESTS MADE IN TACOMA,
WASHINGTON, D.C. AND
NEW YORK CITY.
>> Will: WHAT A WILD SITUATION
TODAY.
THAT THIS RIGHT HERE IS
CONTROVERSIAL, YOU STANDING UP
FOR WOMEN.
WHAT USED TO BE THE EMBODIMENT
OF HUMANISM TODAY IS NOW CALLED
BIGOTRY.
WHAT A FASCINATING AND SAD
MOMENT IN AMER